le garçon de cinq ans a été extirpé d'un
puits tard samedi soir sous les cris
désespérés de la foule massée autour du
site de recherche
il a été transporté en ambulance
finalement la longue et délicate
opération de recherche n'a pas permis de
lui sauver la vie
tout a débuté mardi après-midi le petit
ryan est tombé dans un puits asséché de
32 mètres de profondeur il s'agit d'un
puits étroit creusé près de la résidence
familiale dans le secteur de chefchaouen
l'opération de secours s'est déroulée en
plusieurs étapes
les équipes spécialisées ont d'abord
creusé le terrain parallèle aux puits
par la suite elles ont poursuivi le
forage d'un tunnel horizontale pour
atteindre l'enfant coincé à l'exercice
périlleux en raison du seul friable dans
les derniers jours les secouristes lui
avait fait parvenir de l'oxygène et de
l'eau sans savoir s'ils avaient atteint
leur cible cet accident rappelle une
histoire similaire survenue il ya trois
en espagne un enfant de deux ans avait
été retrouvé mort après avoir chuté dans
un puits abandonné les recherches
s'était échelonné sur 13 jours ici
mélissa françois radio canada montréal